herzlich willkommen zur folge
199 des faz einspruch podcast der
wöchentlichen podcast der faz für recht
justiz und politik heute am 23 februar
2022 my name is khan helmut raß ich bin
berlin korrespondent in der faz und mit
der weiß wie der kia lorenz ich bin
freier journalisten und juristen aus
köln wir stürzen uns gleich in die
themen und kommen mit etwas um die ecke
was schon seit einiger zeit schwelt was
sehr wichtig ist für viele
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher und was
ihr bis jetzt immer ein bisschen links
liegen gelassen haben nämlich die
auswirkungen der strompreise der
wirklich galoppierenden strompreise auf
die verträge von wirklich
hunderttausenden von verbrauchern da
sind nämlich einige discounter pleite
gegangen und haben quasi ihre kunden im
regen stehen lassen und daraus ergibt
sich wirklich eine ganze menge von
rechtlichen fragestellungen die wir
jetzt mal genauer unter die lupe nehmen
wollen damit steigen wir in unsere
sendung ein und was haben wir noch wir
haben einen rechtsstreit von manuela
schwesig die vor dem landgericht hamburg
verloren hat sie wollte dort erreichen
dass ein cdu bundestagsabgeordneter
bestimmte äußerungen die sie als zitate
wahrgenommen hat über sie nicht mehr
wiederholen darf ganz spannend schauen
wir uns mal so an was ist eigentlich
zulässig im politischen meinungskampf
dann hat der europäische gerichtshof ja
in der vergangene woche just zu dem
zeitpunkt der aufnahme unsere sendung
etwas sehr grundsätzliches geklärt zum
rechtsstaats mechanismus das wollten wir
hier natürlich noch mal nach tragen und
wir haben das verwaltungsgericht berlin
mal wieder zum in diesem fall geimpft
status johnson johnson wer ist
eigentlich noch geimpft dazu haben wir
einen kurzen nachtrag mit einem ganz
praktischen bezug auf die frage eines
hörers hin was heißt das denn jetzt
eigentlich für mich neben schwerpunkt
der woche geht es diesmal um einen ganz
abgefahrenen fall die sich dreht um den
rapper bushido und seine wirklich
bestürzt eine freundschaft zu einem
mitglied die einfach echt aus dem ruder
gelaufen ist so kann man sagen diesen
ganz kuriosen fall wird uns mein kollege
sebastian jeder mal näher bringen und
ich kann nur soviel sagen dass ich als
ich mich damit jetzt vertiefter
beschäftigt habe einfach nur dankbar für
meine durchschnittlichkeit war sind auch
ich schön wenn man so reich ist und sich
mit den falschen leuten einlässt und
dann haben wir noch ein bisschen höher
ab rost und ein ungerechtes urteil der
wochen absolut ungerecht klingt er ist
total lustig es kommt aus dem sauerland
vom landgericht arnsberg
es ist am ende gar nicht so lustig
obwohl es um eine 79-jährige stalkerin
im liebeswahn geht ja man darf nicht
vergessen was das mit den opfern dann
auch tut aber da komme ich später zu
[Musik]
gleich zu anfang vielleicht doch noch
mal ein kurzes wort zur ukraine krise
die entwickelt sich ja immer dramatisch
ein krieg erscheint inzwischen
unabwendbar allerdings sind die dinge
auch nur so sehr im fluss dass wir uns
heute in dieser folge noch nicht um die
große weltpolitik kümmern können das
werden wir dann in den kommenden folgen
tun aber ich kann ihnen vielleicht noch
mit die letzte folge ans herz liegen in
folge
198 habe ich schon mit der
völkerrechtlerin anne peters vom max
planck institut über den völkerrechts
bruch gesprochen denen der russische
präsident putin das schon allein dadurch
begeht dass er mit seinen truppen an der
ukrainischen grenze sehr unverhohlen mit
gewalt droht und jetzt ist noch ein
zweiter völkerrechts verstoßen zuge
kommen auch die anerkennung der beiden
völker volksrepublik 'nimm dornbach
können natürlich als einmischung in die
inneren angelegenheiten gewertet werden
und damit als verletzung der
souveränität der ukraine so
allerdings müssen wir es jetzt bei der
großen weltpolitik belassen und kümmern
uns um die strom rechnen so profanes
klingt es gibt insofern einen winzigen
connex sehen wir allerdings auch nicht
überstrapazieren wollen natürlich redet
jetzt auch hier in deutschland alles
über die energiepreise über das was uns
in den kommenden wochen und monaten noch
erwartet ja denn es wird natürlich nicht
besser die gaspreise werden steigen das
ist schon ziemlich sicher und mit daran
hängen natürlich auch immer die
strompreise und das was wir jetzt in der
vergangenheit schon gesehen hat war
gruselig kann man sagen da hat sich ja
schon viel getan und es hat auch schon
dafür gesorgt dass ich schon auch die
deutschen gerichte damit beschäftigen
mussten genau da gab es jetzt einen sehr
interessanten rechtsstreit vor dem
landgericht frankfurt worum ging es da
corinna das landgericht frankfurt hat
den energieversorger mainova untersagt
von neukunden und kunden in der
grundversorgung höhere preise zu
verlangen als von ihren bestandskunden
so und das klingt sehr nüchtern und auch
recht uninteressant
allerdings muss man das ganze so ein
bisschen
aufdröseln denn vielleicht erklären wir
einfach noch mal einen satz oder zwei zu
dem was ich jetzt gerade am strompreis
markt so tut eine strombörse tut die
vielleicht ja auch niemanden oder nicht
fielen jedenfalls so geläufig ist wir
können vielleicht mal klären was ich da
eigentlich getan hat in den vergangenen
monaten an der strombörse lag der
großhandelspreis für elektrizität
2021 im jahresdurchschnitt bei rund
97 euro je megawattstunde und damit
gleich dreimal so hoch wie im vorjahr
und kurz vor weihnachten ging das noch
mal monströs nach oben das waren
aufschläge bis hoch auf
432 euro ja und das war etwas womit
jetzt schon viele energieversorger lange
zeit sich herum geschlagen haben und
besonders die discount versorger waren
davon betroffen es gibt nämlich etliche
unternehmen viele stromversorger die ihm
einerseits wie die stadtwerke ganz
normale
energieversorger sind ganz normal
energie liefern aber es gibt eben auch
viele kleinere unternehmen die sich auch
auf den discount markt breitgemacht
haben also die so ein bisschen wie aldi
und lidl für die stromkunden sind und
ziemlich halsbrecherisch
konditionen angeboten haben also sich
mit sehr niedrigen preisen da fan
geschlagen haben in dem markt und auch
viele kunden angelockt haben das muss
man sagen das war immer verbunden auch
mit der warnung naja was passiert
eigentlich wenn die preise mal wieder
steigen wir hatten sehr lange relativ
niedrige strompreise am markt aber was
passiert eigentlich wenn die mal durch
die decke gehen da wurde auch von den
ganzen verbraucherverbänden schon über
jahre hinweg auch gewarnt aber
es gibt dann doch offensichtlich
hunderttausende kunden die sich da mit
diesen discountern eingelassen haben und
natürlich auch angelockt wurden durch
die niedrigen preisen und jetzt passt
ist genau das passiert was seit jahren
befürchtet wurde nämlich diese massiv
gestiegenen stromkosten ja genau das ist
nämlich dann tatsächlich so gewesen dass
ja um die jahreswende hinweg doch
etliche von diesen discountern
festgestellt haben obst das können wir
uns so nicht mehr leisten ja die
drastisch gestiegenen preise für erdgas
und kohle insbesondere sind ja schuld
daran dass auch die stromerzeugung da
teurer geworden ist und die haben dann
sehr kurzfristig ihre verträge gehabt
mit den stromkunden haben gesagt wir
hören jetzt auf also wir beliefern euch
nicht mehr weil wir uns das schlicht
nicht mehr leisten können etliche sind
auch tatsächlich pleite gegangen also es
ist eine richtige welle durchs land
gegangen wir reden hier immerhin von
drei dutzend versorgern die da in die
knie gegangen sind und dass gute
immerhin liberalisierten strommarkt ist
dass diese kunden nicht etwa im dunkeln
stehen ja und dann mit kerzen und der
kerzenlicht
nur noch bücher lesen können sondern
dass die grundversorger also vor allen
dingen die stadtwerke verpflichtet sind
diese kunden aufzunehmen und da hatten
wir es wirklich mit
größenordnung zu tun die selbst diese
stadtwerke ja schlicht überfordert hat
ja also da ging es eben tatsächlich um
hunderttausende kunden die quer durchs
ganze land aufgenommen werden mussten so
und was haben die sich dann überlegt die
haben sich überlegt dass sie ja selber
dann den strom auf kaufen mussten
aufgrund dieser neuen situation darf
waren sie natürlich auch nicht
vorbereitet und haben dann auch zu
horrenden preisen einkaufen müssen und
dachten sich so ja es jetzt haben wir
zwei möglichkeiten entweder wir geben
das so die ganzen preise machen so eine
mischkalkulation
und heben den tarif für alle in der
grundversorgung oder
wir machen einen gesplitteten tarif und
ja sagen nur unser neukunden dass die
ihm erheblich mehr zahlen müssen so und
viele stadtwerke auch die mainova in
frankfurt hat sich eben für letzteres
entschieden und gesagt wir splitten die
strompreise damit nicht auch noch unsere
anderen kunden sauer werden genau das
heißt die die altkunden quasi die
bestandskunden zeiten die bisherigen
strompreise und die neuen kunden die zum
teil zu tausenden quasi über nacht hinzu
gekommen waren weil sie eben nicht mehr
bei den billigstromanbieter sein konnten
hatten dann zum teil bis zu zwei oder
dreifach höhere strompreise und genau
dagegen hat jetzt ein
unternehmen geklagt dass auch selbst
grundversorger ist richtig ja das ist ja
eine interessante konstellation wir
haben es hier mit etlichen verbrauchern
zu tun die ja wirklich einen preisschock
erlitten haben die ja von sehr billigen
preisen kamen bei diesem discountern die
dänen dann gekündigt wurde und die dann
mit sehr viel höheren preisen auf einmal
konfrontiert waren und natürlich gibt es
auch in diesem bereich etliche die
klagen die sich an verbraucher zentralen
gewandt haben und die über diesen weg
gehen aber den fall den wir jetzt
besprechen das ist ein
wettbewerbsrechtlicher fall wo also ein
kein verbraucher sondern ein konkurrent
geklagt hatte und das war eben
lichtblick das ist so ein
ökostromanbieter der nicht ganz günstig
ist aber der durchaus auch in
verschiedenen regionen der des landes
als grundversorger dient und der eben
sagt na also ganz ehrlich das müssen wir
uns jetzt hier nicht gefallen lassen
also wir haben sauber kalkuliert haben
jetzt vielleicht nicht die günstigsten
preise aber eben auch nicht solche
horrenden preise wie die mainova zum
beispiel um das vielleicht mal noch
einmal deutlich zu machen die mainova
hatte von neukunden in der grund und
ersatzversorgung
anfang januar
79 cent pro kilowattstunde verlangt also
knapp 80 und das ist ein aufschlag von
175 prozent gegenüber dem preis von 32
cent
61 für bestandskunden ja also da hatten
wir schon eine riesige spreizung dann
hat die mainova das übrigens auch gesamt
gesenkt aber an wobei rund 60 cent pro
kilowattstunde aber nichtsdestotrotz hat
der wettbewerber natürlich dagegen
einiges ins feld geführt und ist an ihm
vors landgericht
frankfurt gezogen
und die haben dann dagegen geklagt also
vielleicht noch mal und das um das genau
aufzuschlüsseln sozusagen haben dagegen
geklagt dass die preise so hoch waren
oder haben die dagegen geklagt dass die
die sozusagen die gesamten mehr preise
nur auf die neue kundinnen und kunden
verlagert haben ja also es ging
tatsächlich darum um die grundsätzliche
frage darf ein eine durch die stadtwerke
so ein tarif splitten oder müssen die
all ihre kunden in der grundversorgung
gleich behandeln denn das zum beispiel
tut lichtblick also um das man deutlich
zu sagen es gibt um rund 400 stadtwerke
die das getan haben nicht nur stadtwerke
sondern energieversorger insgesamt da
gibt es ja auch eine ganze menge private
unternehmen da in diesem feld da haben
sich viele viele viele für diesen weg
entschieden ist völlig unklar ob das
überhaupt zulässig ist weil es diese
situation bisher nicht gegeben hat
lichtblick gesagt wir halten das für
unzulässig wir tun's auch nicht und die
haben sich eben haben daraus eine
wettbewerbsrechtliche
auseinandersetzungen gemacht und gesagt
hier verstößt mainova eben ging das
gesetz gegen den unlauteren wettbewerb
und das energiewirtschaftsgesetz und das
landgerichts akio stimmt mal sehen wir
auch sehr genau die hat er
überraschenderweise dann lichtblick
recht gegeben warum sage ich
überraschenderweise weil es schon
zumindest laut mainova andere
entscheidungen gibt von anderen
gerichten die gesagt haben das finden
wir völlig in ordnung das ist ebenso
eine sondersituation was sollen die
grundversorger auch machen wenn und
diese situation ist ja ziemlich
unbenommen das jetzt ist wie hier mit
einem deutlichen preisschock an der
strompreis blase zu tun haben ja wie
sollen die sich sozusagen eindecken das
waren die argumentation der anderen
landgerichte aber man kann auch sagen da
ist natürlich tür und tor für willkür
geöffnet da können dann natürlich die
grundversorger machen was sie wollen da
ist dann können sie das relativ frei
entscheiden wie sie diese tarife oder
auch diese spreizung zwischen den
tarifen gestalten und das kann natürlich
in diesem hoch regulierten markt der
energieversorgung auch nicht sein also
da rechne ich schon damit dass es noch
einige auseinandersetzungen geben wird
wir haben jetzt eben einfach die
situation dass das landgericht aber
zumindest lichtblick mal recht gegeben
hat und gesagt hat
so geht es nicht da kann man vielleicht
sagen das ganze ist jetzt so ein alfa
fan also vielleicht zu der frage mal was
das für die kunden jetzt konkret
bedeutet ist wir sind jetzt in so einer
art übergangsphase also das landgericht
frankfurt hat nun eine einstweilige
verfügung erlassen ja mainova muss damit
die arbeitspreise für den neukunden
tarife in der grund und ersatzversorgung
auf das niveau der anderen anpassen ja
aber dessen ungeachtet
sagt mainova wir halten die entscheidung
für falsch wie gegen gehen dagegen vor
wir werden gegen die einstweilige
verfügung widerspruch einlegen ja und
hoffen auch dass dieses das landgericht
jetzt hier auch im hauptsacheverfahren
den anderen gerichten folgt das heißt
die sache ist jetzt noch nicht
ausgestanden und ich rechne ehrlich
gesagt schon auch damit dass das früher
oder später vor dem bundesgerichtshof
landet ich glaube damit kann und muss
man rechnen das ist ja auch wirklich
eine super komplizierte frage wobei ich
jetzt finde dass die argumentation der
anderen landgerichte so die die
grundversorger müssen ja auch irgendwie
zu sehen wo das geld herkommt und wie
sie die die die zusätzlichen strompreise
zahlen das natürlich total richtig hatte
aber nichts mit der frage zu tun wie ich
die preise verteilt und hier ist ja eben
die frage ist darf ich das alles nur den
neukunden auflasten nur und da hat jetzt
das landgericht frankfurt gesagt nein
das
finde ich eigentlich erst mal ein
tragfähiges argument in das der punkt
ist ja dass das eigentlich ja alles
früher in der kette beginnt das problem
sind ja eigentlich die wie ich sagt auch
nochmal billigstromanbieter die einfach
ihre verträge gekündigt haben und das
alles müssen jetzt die grundversorger
auffangen genau vielleicht um das noch
mal zu sagen das war was ich zitiert
habe war jetzt im klassischen sinne dann
kommen sehr freihändig formuliert ja das
war jetzt nicht und notgedrungen gibt
argumentation der landen landgerichte
die muss ich offen gestehen kenne ich
schlicht und ergreifend nicht das war
jetzt die argumentation der
energieversorger die ihm gesagt hat was
sollen wir denn anders tun wir müssen ja
die die in den strom auch zu höheren
preisen einkaufen und wollen das nicht
an unserer gesamten kunden weitergeben
da ist jetzt sozusagen die rechtliche
dimension ist eher die frage wie viel
spielraum hat eigentlich der
energieversorger bei der gestaltung
dieser
preisklauseln und und der tarif und das
nur um mal quasi deutlich zu machen wie
hier die
argumentationslinien sind wir haben aber
jetzt wie gesagt die konstellation dass
das landgericht
frankfurt zum ersten mal gesagt hat wir
halten diese gesplitteten tarife nicht
für zulässig und
die verbraucherinnen und verbraucher ich
hab da mal so gestern ein bisschen
darüber nachgedacht erst mal bringt den
das ja erst mal gar nichts also nehmen
wir sie nehmen wir mal anders dass diese
entscheidung jetzt überhaupt
rechtskräftig werden würde kann ich dann
als verbraucherin oder verbraucher
hingehen und sagen so liebe mainova
jetzt hätte ich mal gerne mein geld
zurück vermutlich auch noch nicht
na ja doch wenn die
preisklausel unzulässig war dann haben
sie natürlich wird das verrechnet da bin
ich mir schon ziemlich sicher je nachdem
wie das in der hauptsache dann ausgeben
also es gibt jetzt eine konkrete
tarifsenkung das heftigen
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern schon
die frage ob sie geld zurückverlangen
können beziehungsweise das dann mit
anderen kosten verrechnet wird das ist
in der tat etwas was noch geklärt werden
muss aber es gibt ja auch
unterschiedliche möglichkeiten wie
verbraucherinnen und verbraucher jetzt
vorgehen können und das auch das ist ja
heiß diskutiert schon denn die können
sich natürlich auch in erster linie an
ihrer ersten vertragspartner behalten
nämlich an die discounter was natürlich
nur was bringt wenn ihm noch nicht
pleite sind also denn einige von diesen
discountern haben ja auch schon die
grätsche gemacht aber natürlich wenn die
verträge gekündigt wurden aber die
unternehmen existieren dann kann man
sich und das liegt ja auch erst mal in
seinen eigenen vertragspartner wenden
denn wir haben ja schon noch den schönen
alten grundsatz pacta sunt servanda
verträge sind einzuhalten
also ist es natürlich erst mal total
naheliegend als aus sicht von
verbraucherinnen und verbrauchern auf
schadensersatz zu klagen gegen die
billigstromanbieter denen man nämlich
sagt moment mal ich zahle jetzt hier bei
meinem grundversorger weil du mich
einfach raus kriegst das dreifache an
stromkosten und das hätte ich gerne von
dir zurück und das wird ja auch alles
schon vorbereitet zwar in ganz großem
stil
da sind ja schon mehrere liegl tech
unternehmen an die sammeln da jetzt
gerade die klagen zusammen von tausenden
von verbraucher nach an nach eigenen
angaben und wollen wo die ersten bis
ende märz schon ein reichen also ich
glaube da sind jetzt die nächsten
massenklagen zu erwarten die die justiz
wieder mal für jahre bespaßen können und
ich meine das ist natürlich dann auch
eine riesen frage wie hoch ist denn
eigentlich jetzt der schaden wenn man
zum beispiel zudem gegenüber dem
billigstromanbieter wenn man zu dem
ergebnis kam dass die grundversorger
ihre ihre stromrechnungen quasi falsch
kalkuliert haben dann kann ich ja
gegenüber meinem billigstromanbieter
meinen schaden schon gar nicht mehr
richtig beziffern also da lacht ja das
glas juristen herz muss man sagen
denn viele jugendliche
genau verfahren dann ineinander greifen
letztendlich ja also eine komplexe
situation die wirklich daraus entstanden
ist dass wir hier es mit schon jetzt
sehr hohen energiepreisen zu tun haben
schon das hat für ordentlich
verwerfungen an den
strommarkt geführt also man mag sich gar
nicht ausdenken was jetzt noch kommen
wird wie gesagt die beiden rechtlichen
strenge sind die einerseits damit haben
wir jetzt angefangen den
wettbewerblichen streit zwischen den
energieversorgern die natürlich auch auf
faire
wettbewerbsbedingungen pochen und auf
der anderen seite die wirklich
zahlreichen klagen der verbraucher und
verbraucherinnen die einerseits den
strom also die ihren neuen ihren
grundversorger verklagen weil sie eben
denken dass sie darüber verteilt wurden
mit zu hohen tarifen abgespeist wurden
und die andererseits schadensersatz
womöglich von ihrem discounter von ihrem
ehemaligen geschäftspartner quasi
verlangen können also das ist im moment
die rechtlichen mängel lager und ich
würde auch denken das wird uns noch mal
wieder beschäftigen aber ich würde sagen
im moment belassen wir es dabei nicht
wahr
ja dann kommen wir jetzt zu einem sehr
interessanten schlagabtausch zwischen
der ministerpräsidentin von
schleswig-holstein manuela schwesig und
dem hamburger cdu vorsitzenden christoph
ploß corinna du hast die sendung auch
gesehen es ging um eine aussage bei lanz
und
da hat christoph
+1 allgemein kritisiert dass
spd-politiker nord stream zwei nicht in
frage stellen würden obwohl eben an der
ukrainischen grenze die russischen
truppen aufmarschieren und da
möglicherweise invasionen direkt vor der
tür steht und dann hat er über die
ministerpräsidenten von
mecklenburg-vorpommern manuela schwesig
von der spd gesagt ich zitiere und dann
haben sie weitere personen in der
spd-spitze wie manuela schwesig die klar
sagt also diese völker für
rechtsverletzungen die interessieren
mich nicht hauptsache die pipeline kommt
in betrieb sie hat das ziemlich deutlich
gesagt zitat ende
schwesig hat daraufhin eine einstweilige
verfügung beantragt und zwar mit der
relativ einfachen begründung das sei
eine falsche tatsachenbehauptung sie
habe nichts derartiges gesagt und jetzt
hat das landgericht hamburg entschieden
ja und das ist ja in der tat nicht
wirklich sehr interessante gemengelagen
also wir haben hier eine land sendung
wie sie ja dreimal die woche vorkommt
die insofern war sie auch wirklich
nichts bemerkenswertes das war lars
klingbeil da der neue spd chef ist war
eben herbster sie haben natürlich über
die ukraine krise gesprochen und die
haltung der spd zu nord stream 2 also zu
der neuen gasleitung die ja vier schon
seit monaten wenn nicht jahren
eigentlich für große werbung sorgt für
großen streit auch mit den vereinigten
staaten also keine einfache gemengelage
die spd hat dazu immer eine sehr
gespaltene haltung gehabt eine sehr nord
stream zwei freundliche haltung wohl
wissend dass das mit dem russischen
präsidenten putin ja alles nicht ganz
einfach ist dass wir uns da erneut und
weiter in eine tiefe tiefe abhängigkeit
mit dem russischen präsidenten
begeben und das war eben die also doch
sehr kühne aussage von herrn plus in
dieser zdf-show lanz vom 8 februar also
da merkt man schon auch in dem es ein
paar wochen her aber schon da war ja die
krise allgegenwärtig und vor allen
dingen die rolle der spd heißt
diskutiert und ich muss sagen ich bin da
schon sehr über diese
über diese sehr kühne aussage
gestolpert war ich dachte das ist eine
sehr gewagte
überspitzung der haltung der spd
ministerpräsidenten immer muss er dazu
mal sagen sie ist ja
[Musik]
ministerpräsidentin des bundeslandes wo
die gaspipeline tatsächlich auf trifft
ja wo auch es wirtschaftlich eine große
rolle spielen wird die auch immer
vehement aus diesen gründen eben die
gaspipeline sehr gefördert und
unterstützt hat das ist unbenommen aber
dann zu sagen na ja also die
völkerrechtsverletzungen interessieren
mich hauptsache die pipeline kommt ist
natürlich etwas was schon definitiv eine
politische und das überspitzung ist aber
dann umso
dann war ihm so ungewöhnlich dass
manuela schwesig überhaupt dagegen
vorgegangen ist oder und dagegen
vorgegangen heißt er in dem fall auch
ich schalte auf staatskosten dann
anwälte ein mit denen ich mich wehre und
das ist jetzt schon sehr sehr
ungewöhnlich innerhalb des politischen
meinungskampf wenn ich meine dass da der
eine dem anderen oder der anderen mal
dinge in den in den mund legt die
vielleicht nicht ganz so gesagt worden
sind wird es dann wieder gegeben wird
von der politischen gegenseite das ist
jetzt nicht gerade eine seltenheit dass
man deshalb irgendwie vor gericht zieht
ist
vor allen dingen weil ja auch lars
klingbeil in der spd vorsitzende in der
sendung saß und ihr auch vehement
widersprochen hat und ihn auch mehrfach
herrn plus im 2 gefallen ist und dort
nicht gesagt hat so hat sie das gar
nicht gesagt na also man kann schon
sagen der äußere eindruck war schon der
einer sehr politischen
auseinandersetzung und das frau manuela
schwesig da jetzt mit rechtlichen
mitteln
ein gerät ist schon sehr ungewöhnlich
was hat sie gemacht sie hat erst mal vom
cdu vorsitz im plus dann eine
unterlassungserklärung verlangt das ist
so der übliche weg in diesem
zusammenhang dass man einfach betreuern
muss dass man so etwas nicht nochmal
wiederholt darauf hat er sich ebenfalls
sehr medienwirksam nicht eingelassen hat
das auf twitter so erklärt dass er sich
da dem nicht beugen wolle sondern bei
seiner haltung bleibe ja und dann musste
ihm das landgericht hamburg entscheiden
wir haben ja letzte woche schon mal
erwähnt dass das gerne eingeschaltet
wird in diesem zusammenhang bei
meinungsäußerungen auch hier ist das
durchaus nachvollziehbar weil die show
von herrn lanz ja auch in hamburg
aufgezeichnet wird und herb los
natürlich auch aus hamburg kommt so und
jetzt geht es sozusagen um die frage
gelten hier die maßstäbe des zitat
schutzes ja wie bewerten wir sozusagen
diese einheit ist das
ganz klar als zitat gekennzeichnet soll
das ein zitat gewesen sein und dann muss
es auch zumindest irgendwie in diese
richtung so darf mal gefallen seien ja
also auch in diesem zusammenhang oder
geht es nur darum dass herr post die
haltung von frau schwesig wieder geben
wollte und nicht direkt ein zitat
wiedergeben heute und dann gelten eben
einfach die grundsätze der
meinungsfreiheit und solange irgendein
tatsächliche anknüpfungspunkt für diese
meinung besteht muss diese auch dann
zulässig sein und man kann davon
ausgehen dass das landgericht hamburg
offensichtlich dieser zweiten meinung
angehangen ist also die die rechtsfrage
ist ja tatsächlich wie kommt das
sozusagen bei den zuschauerinnen und
zuschauern an also gehen die zuschauer
jetzt davon aus dass er dass herr plus
mit dieser sehr zugespitzten aussage
tatsächlich wiedergibt was frau schwesig
gesagt hat im sinne eines wortwörtlichen
zitat oder wille ihre haltung bewährten
politisch bewerten und dann wäre es hat
eine meinungsäußerung und offensichtlich
hat sich dieser letzteren meinung das
landgericht hamburg angeschlossen das
landgericht hat nur den antrag auf
erlass einer einstweiligen
unterlassungsverfügung
zurückgewiesen weil es die äußerung ihm
in diesem kontext nicht als wiedergabe
eines zitat von schwesig
gewertet hat sondern als zugespitzte
politische meinungsäußerung ja und da
handelt es sich also auch gerade dieses
das etwas die formulierung jemand sage
etwas handelt sich so sehen das die
richter um ein stilmittel um politische
positionen zusammenfassen
um politische positionen
zusammenzufassen und nicht um eine
wörtliche wiedergabe
unterstellen die richter ja auch noch
auf den letzten satz ab den er dann
hinterher geschoben hat nämlich sie hat
das ziemlich deutlich gesagt und ich
finde das auch relativ überzeugend dass
man spätestens eigentlich mit diesem
satz sagt naja das ist jetzt hier keine
wörtliche wiedergabe von dem was manuela
schwesig von sich gegeben hat sondern
das ist quasi meine zusammenfassung
dessen was ich davon verstehe so durch
diese oder was genau genau
was die kann man sich auch noch
angeguckt hat war eben diesen dieser
zweite teil in dem schloss den satz
gesagt hat also diese
völkerrechtsverletzungen interessieren
mich nicht dass er gerade zu karikieren
dass er dann noch hinzugefügt hat im
hauptsache die pipeline kommen also und
da das kann ich mir schon vorstellen
das ist etwas wo sich der der zuhörer
schon vorstellen kann na ja das wird sie
so nicht gesagt haben das wäre einfach
zu eklatant ja das wird sie im zweifel
eigentlich eher ausgeblendet haben ja
und ihm gerade nicht in ihrer überlegung
einbezogen haben aber so wie herr plus
es eben darstellt ist das nach ansicht
der kammer karikierend gewesen und dann
deshalb auch für alle deutlich als
überspitzung gemeint so und wie findest
du das ich finde das total tragfähig ich
bin gerade so begeistert von dieser
entscheidung des landgerichts hamburg
also weil ich ich tue mich immer schwer
damit so diese ganz strengen maßstäbe
des äußerung des rechts im politischen
meinungskampf anzuwenden
und zwar auch so ein bisschen mit dem
mit dem berühmten wo kommen wir denn da
hin argument wenn ihr ganz ehrlich in
jeder land so in zukunft die politiker
übereinander irgendwie dann vor gericht
ziehen und sagen aber das habe ich so
nie gesagt wie du es mir unterstellt
hass und in den mund gelegt hast und
keine ahnung was herr markus söder wer
auch immer ganz ehrlich dann können wir
keinen politischen meinungskampf mehr
führen und im politischen meinungskampf
muss halt mehr erlaubt sein als
ansonsten und ich finde eigentlich dass
die äußerung von herrn plus in diesem
fall ganz klar als wertende also als
seine meinung über das was manuela
schwesig gesagt hat zu erkennen waren
und dass wenn man das anders sehen würde
glaube ich würde man jetzt auch die idee
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer deutlich
unterschätzen ja und wie gesagt aus dem
gesamtzusammenhang herrling mal hatte
heftig widersprochen so dass ich da auch
ein sehr rundes bild ergeben hat ja dann
lassen wir doch jetzt dieses thema mal
hinter uns und kommen zum nächsten blog
ja und da beschäftigen wir uns jetzt mit
dem europäischen gerichtshof und der
entscheidung die im vergangenen mittwoch
gefällt wurde in bezug auf ungarn und
polen
jetzt jedoch genau in bezug auf den
sogenannten rechtsstaats mechanismus den
hat der ogh
gebilligt das war jetzt nicht weiter
überraschend trotzdem ist es wichtig
deshalb wollen wir uns dann euch das
heute noch mal mitbringen obwohl sie
jetzt eben schon eine woche alt ist weil
wieder parallel aufgezeichnet haben
während der reha das in der letzten
woche veröffentlicht hat was ist der
rechtsstaat mechanismus wie n und
vermutlich nicht alle daran deshalb noch
einmal ganz kurz
2018 hat die eben kommission dieses
institut vorgeschlagen und zwar geht es
letztlich darum dass finanzierung der eu
stärker daran gekoppelt werden dass die
mitgliedstaaten sich rechtsstaatlich
verhalten so nennt man auch
konditionalität verordnung scheint jetzt
irgendwie so ein neues hippes wort dafür
zu sein vielleicht ist es ganz gut weil
man das deshalb damit besser
unterscheiden kann von dem artikel
sieben verfahren also es gibt ja dieses
artikel sieben verfahren das sich
bislang eher als zahnloser tiger erweist
mit dem die eu gegen mitgliedsstaaten
vorgehen kann wenn die bestimmte
grundwerte der eu nicht einhalten das
ist aber gar nicht so richtig klar was
eigentlich am ende dabei herauskommen
kann und in diesem fall eben beim
konditionalität verfahren nach der
konditionalität verordnung geht es dann
schlicht als gilt also die eu kann
haushaltsmittel kürzen wenn in einem
mitgliedstaat
missbrauch des geldes droht wegen
rechtsverstößen oder sonstwie wenn sonst
wie von grundwerten der eu abgewichen
wird der gedanke ist irgendwie klar wir
geben euch nämlich kein geld aus der eu
wenn wir nicht kontrollieren können weil
eigentlich niemand kontrollieren kann
wie diese eu gelder eingesetzt werden
weil die justiz in den mitgliedsstaaten
stark kontrolliert wird also weil dort
zum beispiel nicht mehr gewährleistet
ist dass die gewaltenteilung
funktioniert also es keine justiz mehr
gibt die den staat und die regierung
kontrollieren würde die ganze kiste ist
im januar 20 21 in kraft getreten und
eigentlich gab es direkt ärger von so
ziemlich allen seiten das
europaparlament hat dann nämlich richtig
druck gemacht diesen rechtsstaats
mechanismus jetzt auch anzuwenden direkt
und zwar natürlich gegen wen gegen polen
ungarn da sind so ein bisschen die sie
lagen etwas verschiedenen ungarn gibt es
tatsächlich er immer so ein bisschen um
korruptionsprobleme vor allem im umfeld
die regierung in polen geht es darüber
haben wir auch hier podcast schon sehr
oft gesprochen
vor allem darum dass die justiz da so
gebaut wird also bastard faktisch die
justiz immer mehr in richtung
staatsapparat abdriftet dass die
gewaltenteilung sich zunehmend auflöst
und dass die babys also die
regierungspartei die sehr
nationalkonservative regierungspartei
zunehmend dafür sorgt dass eigentlich an
den gerichten keine richterinnen und
richter mehr sitzen die ihre
entscheidungen aufheben würden und
deswegen haben polen und ungarn weil die
sich sofort gedacht haben ist die ganze
kiste konnte gegen uns ausgehen dagegen
geklagt und über diese klage hat der bgh
jetzt entschieden das ging sehr sehr fix
eben weil auch das parlament auf der
anderen seite schon riesen stress
gemacht hat und gesagt hat werden wir
diese das jetzt aber haben dieses
instrument dann sollten wir es jetzt
auch mal anwenden und nicht weiterhin
mehr oder weniger tatenlos zuschauen wie
die rechtsstaatlichkeit vor allem
empfohlen ja abgebaut wird und dass die
faktor dahin geht sozusagen und die
europäische kommission hat sich eben
immer zurückgehalten mit dem einsatz
dieses instruments weil sie gesagt haben
denn wir wissen ja dass hier klagen
anhängig sind wir warten jetzt erstmal
ab was der bgh dazu sagt hoffend und
wohl wissen was da rauskommen würde
nämlich der ogh hat es abgesegnet oder
der harz abgesegnet man kann vielleicht
noch mal kurz sagen dieses verhalten der
eu kommission lag auch ein bisschen
daran dass es im jahr 2020 so eine art
ist nochmal stillhalteabkommen gab mit
polen und ungarn damals ging es nämlich
darum dass die polen und die ungarn ihre
blockade aufheben sollten von wichtigen
eu haushaltsentscheidungen und dann hat
die kommission gesagt kommen irgendwie
wir kriegen das ohne euch nicht durch
das heißt wir schalten jetzt so lange
kein rechtsstaats mechanismus hier ein
wenn ihr wie wie der ogh noch nicht
entschieden hat und ihr stimmt jetzt
erstmal zu damit wir diese
haushaltsentscheidungen hier freigeben
können unter anderem ging es hat damals
auch eine sehr sehr hohe corona
zahlungen und dann war so ein bisschen
jetzt ich glaube man ungefähr ein jahr
ruhe im karton und jetzt hat der ogh
eben entschieden und hat die klagen von
ungarn und aus polen gegen den ich sage
es nochmal konditionalität mechanismus
abgewiesen der euro hat also gesagt das
geht in ordnung wenn die eu den erhalt
von mitteln aus dem unions haushalt
davon abhängig macht dass die
mitgliedstaaten die grundsätze der
rechtsstaatlichkeit einhalten neugier
hat das jetzt noch mal ganz kurz für die
johannes gesagt die rechtsgrundlage
passt schon das ist auch mit dem artikel
sieben verfahren vereinbar also dieses
andere verfahren das es eben gibt es
dann mitgliedstaaten nicht mehr bei
kommt weil die grundwerte so zusagen
nicht einhalten der union und es ist
auch im einklang mit den grenzen der
zuständigkeiten der union und auch mit
dem grundsatz der rechtssicherheit hat
sich also recht detailliert mit allen
einwänden aus polen ungarn beschäftigt
und hat schon auch gesagt also es geht
hier nicht darum dass man grundsätzlich
einfach verstöße gegen die grundsätze
der rechtsstaatlichkeit ahndet mini
mitgliedstaaten sondern voraussetzung
dafür dass man diesen mechanismus
anwenden also auf deutsch gesagt
haushaltsmittel nicht auszahlen darf in
die mitgliedstaaten ist dass es um den
unions haushalt geht also darum geht den
haushalt vor beeinträchtigungen zu
schützen die sich unmittelbar aus
verstößen gegen die rechtsstaatlichkeit
in dem mitgliedstaat
ergeben und der bh hat das schon auch
noch mal so ein bisschen mit partners
gemacht muss man sagen hat noch mal
gesagt so hey wir sprechen hier von den
gemeinsamen werten der union quasi wir
sind hier nicht nur eine
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft sozusagen
und hat gesagt da die achtung der
gemeinsamen werte somit eine
voraussetzung für den genuss all jene
rechte ist die sich aus der anwendung
der verträge auf einen mitgliedsstaat
ergeben muss die union auch in der lage
sein diese werte im rahmen der ihr
übertragenen aufgaben zu verteidigen und
dann sehr realistisch halt der haushalt
also deutsch gesagt die kohle ist eines
der wichtigsten instrumente um den
grundsatz der solidarität zwischen den
mitgliedstaaten zu konkretisieren das
kann man wohl so sagen wenn nicht alle
sind damit nach mehreren stellen
übrigens ne das kann man total gerecht
finden das hat das vielleicht auch an
das gerechte urteile auch schaffen
können also das ist tatsächlich keine
überraschende entscheidung eigentlich
hatte jeder damit gerechnet dass der ogh
das belegen würde aber ich finde es
schon sehr wichtig dass er das auch zum
anlass genommen hat eben diese
grundwerte der union auch noch mal so zu
betonen und zu sagen ihr geht es auch
eben nicht nur irgendwie darum dass wir
uns gegenseitig mit geldern unterstützen
sondern das geld ist im prinzip nur das
mittel dafür dass wir alle dass wir
dafür sorgen können dass wir alle die
gleichen grundwerte verfolgen das finde
ich schon relativ wichtig und auch schön
ausgedrückt wieder das so gemacht hat
wenn ich gesagt habe das ist ein
gerechtes urteil muss man fairerweise
dazusagen dass sehen natürlich nicht
alle so in ungarn und in polen ist das
natürlich auf große ablehnung gestoßen
ja da ist es natürlich einmischung der
eu in das selbstbestimmungsrecht der
länder und so weiter das übliche das war
ja auch so ein bisschen erwartungsgemäß
und im moment muss man vermutlich auch
davon ausgehen dass er jetzt erst mal
gar nicht so richtig viel passiert also
theoretisch könnte jetzt auf vorschlag
der kommission dann der rat
schutzmaßnahmen ergreifen also bedeutet
zahlungen aussetzen oder auch genehmigt
die programme aussetzen die halt schon
eigentlich durchgegangen sind und mit
denen die mitgliedstaaten rechnen aber
jetzt sind quasi alle augen gerichtet
auf myvideo auf die
kommissionspräsidentin und ursula von
der leyen hatte sich immer so ein
bisschen durch laviert und hat immer
gesagt wir haben vorhin schon gesagt wir
leiten hier noch kein verfahren gegen
ungarn und polen bis der euch
entschieden hat wir gucken uns dann er
das erst mal an so weit ist es jetzt
halt und so richtig schnell scheint es
nicht zugehen jetzt heißt es jetzt werde
man erst mal unter berücksichtigung der
ogh urteile in den kommenden wochen
leitlinien annehmen die mehr klarheit
darüber bieten wie wir den mechanismus
in der praxis anwenden das kann man
jetzt schon etwas erstaunlich finden
weil man ja weiß dass der mechanismus
eigentlich schon seit über einem jahr in
der praxis anwendbar wäre und man nur
gesagt hat wir machen es jetzt noch
nicht weil wir erst mal abwarten was der
ogh dazu sagt jetzt sind aber im april
auch noch in ungarn wahlen das heißt das
könnte durchaus als einmischung in den
wahlkampf gewährt werden von den ungarn
vielleicht könnte es sogar willkommen
das futter für irgendwelche anti eu
kampagnen liefern das will man ist jetzt
natürlich meine unterstellung vermutlich
auch nicht unbedingt verursachen auf
seiten der kommission also ich glaube
dass man damit rechnen kann dass das
jetzt vielleicht aus einigen wochen und
leitfäden zu entwickeln und leitlinien
anzunehmen auch noch einige monate
werden könnten so dass zumindest die
wahlen in ungarn vorbei sein sollten und
da geht es echt und relativ viel geld
also polen hat jetzt 10 netto so um die
zwölf milliarden euro von der eu
bekommen jährlich und es geht natürlich
um wahnsinnig viele corona hilfen die
auf block blockiert sind derzeit und bei
umgang geht es glaube ich um irgend
sowas zwischen sechs und sieben
milliarden euro also das ist schon
richtig viel und für die länder
natürlich wahnsinnig ärgerlich man darf
aber echt gespannt sein ob da jetzt was
kommt von der kommission und wenn ja
wann denn das mittel wäre jetzt da es
ist gerichtlich abgesegnet und
eigentlich gibt es nicht mehr so richtig
gute politische oder rechtliche gründe
noch zu warten und sich dass die
zustände vor allem in polen beim abbauen
der dortigen des dortigen justizsystems
noch weiter anzuschauen
gut also dass zu diesem thema
[Musik]
kommen wir jetzt in aller kürze tommy
klings thema
ist es wenn man eine bombe das ist auf
jeden fall das thema das wir in den
vergangenen wochen am häufigsten
gesprochen haben
also konkret wir sind jetzt damit wir
unsere hörerinnen und hörer mitnehmen
gedanklich beim
nicht zwar nicht genesen staates sondern
jetzt impfstatus dem status des
vollständig geimpften was bedeutet das
eigentlich in dem modernen corona weht
hat ja auch einige veränderungen
genommen in den letzten wochen und auch
dazu hat sich das verwaltungsgericht
berlin vergangene woche geäußert das
wollten wir hier an dieser stelle der
vollständigkeit halber
darstellen und vielleicht auch ganz kurz
erklären was das für die betroffenen
bedeutet es ist sehr konsequent zu ende
gedacht das was wir wie gesagt schon
häufiger gesprochen haben also was ist
eigentlich mitte januar da passiert als
auf einmal
bundestag bundesrat und bundesregierung
ihre macht aus der hand gegeben haben
bisher wie gesagt war die der genesenen
status und auch der geimpft status in
einem in einer verordnung in einer
bundesverordnung geregelt mit 19
schutzmaßnahmen ausnahmeverordnung ja
schön dass sie an dieser stelle nochmal
erwähnt das ist immer kann man richtig
kann man nicht oft genug tun da war es
eben sehr übersichtlich war da zu lesen
dass der genesene status über einen
zeitraum von sechs monaten sich
erstreckte und dann war auch deutlich
festgelegt wann man vollständig geimpft
ist nämlich grundsätzlich nach einer
zweifachen impfung
mit den herkömmlichen impfstoffen es sei
denn man ist mit johnson & johnson
geimpften reicht eben eine impfung das
war ja das womit wir jetzt wir haben ja
lang mindestens gelebt haben es war so
das worauf sich die politik geeinigt
hatte und dann kam es ja zu der änderung
dieser wunderbaren verordnung und da hat
die politik quasi die entscheidung
dirigiert an zwei bundesbehörde nämlich
zum genesenen status an das lka an das
robert-koch-institut und zum thema wer
ist eigentlich vollständig geimpft hat
jetzt das paul ehrlich institut die
hoheit und beide institute haben da
ziemlich schnell und rigoros gehandelt
jeweils das nur auf ihrer internetseite
veröffentlicht nämlich der genießen
status wurde verkürzt von sechs auf drei
monate und die johnson & johnson
geimpften hatten das nachsehen die
wurden jetzt nur dann als vollständig
geimpft angesehen wenn sie sich zweimal
haben impfen lassen und ihm bin nicht
wie bisher einmal so und das hat
natürlich für etliche leute dramatischen
unterschied gemacht im täglichen die ja
weil man ja im in zeiten von 2g da ja
auf diese stadt russe angewiesen ist
genau wüsste morgens wach und schwupps
bist du plötzlich nicht mehr geimpft
oder genesen und darfst nicht mehr
so und das hat natürlich für
verwerfungen gesorgt übrigens
interessanterweise mit so einer gewissen
nach laufzeit das hat ein weilchen
gedauert bis die politik gebracht hat
was sie da eigentlich gemacht haben aber
auch die verwaltungsgerichte sind
aufgewacht insbesondere das
verwaltungsgericht berlin das hat vor
zwei wochen ist schon deutlich gemacht
na also hier beim genießen status diese
änderungen durch das lka war
rechtswidrig und analog haben sie jetzt
das gleiche entschieden für den
impfstatus johnson & johnson auch hier
noch mal kurz die haupt argumentation
zusammengefasst es geht eben einfach
darum dass der gesetzgeber nicht einfach
so dass eine bundesbehörde die
delegierten darf so eine wichtige
entscheidung denn die
verordnungsermächtigung im
infektionsschutzgesetz
richtet sich eben an die bundesregierung
an niemanden sonst und die hat zu
entscheiden wer feuchte nicht geimpft
und wir genießen ist so und da war das
ist haben ja jetzt schon mehrere
verwaltungsgerichte so entschieden und
auch das bundesverfassungsgericht hat in
der vergangenen woche recht deutlich
gemacht dass das sowohl doch endlich
geht mit dieser sogenannten doppelten
verweisung also der dynamische
verweisung was ist denn jetzt an der
entscheidung aus berlin so besonders
zum ersten mal hat sie eben johnson
johnson betroffene bisher ging es immer
um den genießen status und auch das hat
ja wirklich sehr zur verwerfung geführt
und es ist auch jetzt sehr deutlich das
hat das verwaltungsgericht gesagt ist
wir sind zuständig und zwar nur wir
warum weil es eben eine verordnung des
bundes ist und nicht der einzelnen
länder und da ist eben dann das
verwaltungsgericht berlin
zuständig so hat es das auch klar gesagt
auch öffentlich gemacht und jetzt hat
das natürlich den salat jetzt kommen die
kläger aus dem ganzen bundesgebiet zumal
so alle menschen die sich jetzt dagegen
wehren wollen dass sie zum beispiel
nicht mehr als geimpft gelten weil sie
nur einmal mit johnson johnson geimpft
wurden oder auch alle menschen die gerne
ihren sechs monats genesen status zurück
hätten sollen und müssen sich jetzt auch
als vg berlin wenden gerichtliche ja und
das ist eben das ein bisschen das
dilemma weil diese entscheidungen sind
gelten immer nur für den einzelfall
heißt das verwaltungsgericht was immer
es entscheidet kann das nicht einmal
grundsätzlich klären das geht übrigens
in anderen bundesländern aber hier nicht
bei uns in berlin dh es müssen
tatsächlich alle leute einzeln klagen
die politik hat schon ein einsehen das
muss man fairerweise an dieser stelle
sagen ist gut
also die haben jetzt endlich auch mal ja
einsehen aber
man weiß noch nicht genau was warum
kommt muss man ehrlicherweise sagen wo
und wann was darunter genau und länder
haben schon festgestellt wir wollen das
wieder rückgängig machen aber
inwieweit und ob das auch bedeutet dass
wir uns inhaltlich wieder anders
positionieren also dass wir zurückgehen
zu den sechs monaten und zu der
doppelten zu der einfachen impfungen bei
johnson johnson ist ehrlich gesagt
völlig unklar weil sich die gerichte
auch einige soweit ich das überblicke
wie inhaltlich geäußert haben was sie
jetzt nun richtig finden sondern immer
nur gesagt haben sich formell das
formelle argument gestützt haben und
gesagt haben kinder ist wie es
konstruiert hat ist das schlicht falsch
und unzulässig so darf es nicht gehen so
das heißt es wir haben es hier wirklich
mit einem sehr sehr müde den prozess zu
tun ich finde auch dass kann man da kann
man gar nicht müde werden dass
anzuprangern das ist einfach zu dafür
dass es wirklich viele menschen täglich
betrifft also hat sich die politik hier
wirklich nicht mit ruhm bekleckert nicht
bei der bei dem eigentlichen mechanismus
nicht bei der kommunikation und auch
nicht bei dem aufräumen des schlamassels
in wann etwa dass die neue regelung
kommt und wie die aussieht da sind
tappen wir noch völlig im unklaren das
heißt die leute sind darauf geworfen
sich tatsächlich einzeln vor gericht zu
werden und das kann natürlich nicht sinn
und zweck dieser ganzen übung sein ist
meine bescheidene meinung
völlig zu recht aber ich glaube die die
kann auch kaum jemand anders vertreten
also so einen ähnlichen fehler nach fast
zwei jahren pandemie zu machen von dem
wirklich von der ersten sekunde an
absehbar war dass diese dynamische
verweisung als rk ii und das an dass
pelé nicht halten würde in so relevanten
fragen also da fehlt mir auch ein
bisschen das verständnis dafür muss ich
sagen uns warum es jetzt noch so lange
dauert das ganze wieder zu bereinigen
na ja also ich glaube bundestag und
bundesrat müssen über änderungen der
verordnung dieser regierungsverordnung
eben dann wieder entscheiden und ich
weiß nicht wann die nächste
bundestagssitzung ist aber das dauert
auf jeden fall ein bisschen mehr wir
sind ja alle genau im märz richtig wir
wissen ja alles bewegen karneval musste
das im februar alles ausfallen und
deswegen wird da wohl jetzt so schnell
nichts passieren und bis dahin können
die leute noch den gerichten die bude
einrennen und selber geld investieren
und das ganze für nix so werden jetzt
auf uns aufzuregen würde ich sagen ihr
müsst jetzt alle zum vg berlin gehen
wenn ihr euren geimpft oder genesen den
status wiederhergestellt haben wollte ja
da war belassen wir es jetzt
dann kommen wir jetzt zu einem fall der
seit eineinhalb jahren hier am
landgericht berlin verhandelt wird ein
prozess mit unglaublicher prominenz denn
es wird ein fall verhandelt in dem es um
eine bedrohung geht um eine erpressung
gegenüber von bushido dem
erfolgreichsten rapper dorthin so kann
man ihnen
benennen und zwar richtet sich dieses
verfahren gegen abou chaker und sah drei
seiner brüder also ein clan mitglied das
hier auch in berlin für sehr großen
wirbel sorgt große prominenz genießt und
gleichzeitig auch sehr gefürchtet ist
und dieser prozess schleppt sich jetzt
schon seit ewigkeiten
vorwärts und kommt doch nicht so richtig
über die ziellinie und darüber möchte
ich jetzt mit meinem kollegen sebastian
eder sprechen erst nämlich redakteur im
ressort gesellschaft bei fasnet und
außerdem unglaublicher web und clan
kenner herzlich willkommen sebastian
schön dass du da bist hallo
für uns doch noch mal ein schlecht
können wir einmal ganz am anfang sagen
was eigentlich die vorwürfe sind denn
die haben es nämlich in sicht worum geht
es da
ja also der kern des vorwurfs ist
eigentlich ein treffen zwischen diesen
beiden personen bei denen china
eingesperrt und bedroht und beleidigt
worden sein soll aber um das zu
verstehen um was es da eigentlich muss
man glaube ich ein bisschen weiter
ausholen
wie sich diese beiden akteure überhaupt
kennengelernt haben genau erzählen uns
doch mal wer ist dieser bushido
eigentlich also alle die jetzt in den
letzten 20 jahren ihren kopf in den sand
gesteckt haben und keine ahnung wer
bushido ist werden jetzt von hier auf
geklärt wer ist dieser mann
bushido war muss man glaube ich sagen
lange zeit der erfolgreichste rapper
deutschlands also bestimmt zehn 15 jahre
so ab anfang der nuller jahre bis 2016
17 18 sowas und er hat eben diesen
diesen aufstieg zusammen geschafft mit
einer förderbescheid der sein manager
war
und das hat so angefangen dass bushido
zu ihm gegangen ist weil er ärger mit
seinem alten label hatte wo er schon
akku berlin war das dann war er schon
erfolgreich wollte aber irgendwann raus
da gab es irgendwelche unstimmigkeiten
und dann haben die ihnen nicht
rausgelassen oder da gibt es
verschiedene versionen warum das nicht
geklappt hat und dann hat er sich eben
hilfe bei af atemschaukel geholt und
dann haben die zusammen als team kann
man schon sagen eben sehr lange diese
szene dominiert in deutschland
jetzt muss uns doch ein paar worte zu
alpha busacca
geben ein bisschen erzählen das ist ja
wirklich eine ziemlich zwielichtige
typen
ja da kommt eben aus einer bekannten
berliner klaren familie und hat da eben
sehr viel zu sagen was ich auch dadurch
entwickelt hat eben durch diese
verbindung zur bushido weil er da
es halt geschafft hat sehr viel geld
reinzuholen und das ja auch auf dem
legalen weg dadurch ist das einen seinen
einfluss irgendwie gestiegen und der ist
journalist - drinnen gestalt
aufgestiegen und hat diese inszenierung
als gefährliche clan chef der da
irgendwie berlin den untergrund regiert
hatte er halt auch eine weile lang sehr
mit befördert weil es wird jetzt ein
film gedreht über bushido da ist er auch
mit auf dem roten teppich
gedanken und der wird eben genau dieses
bild dieser gefährlichen plan figur
gezeichnet und der es in musikvideos
aufgetreten von bushido und hat eben
auch so ein bisschen die die
drecksarbeit für ihn gemacht also wenn
es jetzt streit mit anderen rappern grab
dann sagen die anderen rappern hat halt
auf dass das telefon geklingelt und dann
bleiben am telefon und mit dem volt und
dann selbst die härtesten jungs
möglichst keinen ärger haben und das hat
eben dazu geführt dass bushido dann sehr
gut dastanden der rap-szene weil er halt
alle beleidigen konnte und keiner konnte
ihn so richtig paroli bieten weil sonst
halt auf andere ebene als ärger ist ein
wichtiger wettbewerbsvorteil im markt
genommen genau
vielleicht muss man fairerweise da auch
nochmal einordnen also dieser arafat
apotheker ist geht eben ein sehr
zwielichtige figur die ganze familie ist
sehr verwoben und auch sehr bekannt
in dem ganzen milieu der organisierten
kriminalität wie viel allerdings kann
man den ihm auch tatsächlich nachweisen
denn ich war aber sehr erstaunt zu sehen
dass er also vorbestraft ist er nicht
mehr genau also nicht vorbestraft es
gibt ganz viele verfahren wie
eingestellt wurden gegen ihn und
wahrscheinlich ist dass jetzt halt auch
ein grund dass die berliner justiz sich
gesagt hat und hier jetzt haben wir hier
den ängsten begleiter von oder ein
längsten mit leiter von db schenker der
mit uns spricht und der uns alle sagt
weil er halt eben selbst probleme hat
und dieses verhältnis auflösen will und
haben da so eine art kronzeuge und jetzt
haben wir da eben ein hauptgewinn und
können ihm jetzt mal richtig vor gericht
auseinander nehmen so ein bisschen also
glaub ich war so ein bisschen die
vorstellung und es klappt halt nicht so
wichtig wie die sagen den letzten 100
jahren genau also denn es geht es schon
seit anderthalb jahren also wir haben
mehrere dutzend
verhandlungstage schon rg gesehen auch
unter sehr großer medialer
aufmerksamkeit war natürlich viele
namenhafte leute da als zeugen ausgesagt
haben nicht zuletzt bushido auch und
seine frau ja genau 25 tage lang
ausgesagt und hat im grunde genommen
erzählt was ihm damals widerfahren ist
jetzt kommen nochmal zu dem
sagenumwobenen
treffen wann war das genau
am 18 januar 2018 schon was soll da
eigentlich passiert sein also
es war dann ebenso dass bushido und
arafat ich wüsste auch umstritten von
wem es jetzt richtig aus ging aber die
geschäftliche beziehung sollte eben
aufgelöst werden bushido stellt ist oder
dass er aus diesem verhältnis aussteigen
wollte und von der bescheid hat das
nicht zugelassen habe und dieser streit
hat sich dann halt so hochgeschaukelt
und dann an diesem 18 januar soll es
laut bushido solle er eingestellt worden
seien in das büro von
von apotheker soll dann da eingesperrt
worden seien die brüder von von arafat
waren auch da die stehen ja mit ihm auch
vor gericht und dann soll er da in
bedroht worden sein beschimpft worden
sein mit einer plastikflasche geschlagen
ein stuhl auf ihn geworfen und also er
stellt es so dar dass er relativ
traumatisiert aus diesem büro wieder
rausgekommen ist nach nach viereinhalb
stunden da und das ist eigentlich also
viele dieser diese vorwürfe die gegen
die apotheker erhoben werden beziehen
sich eben tatsächlich auch auf dieses
eine treffen so und da geht es eben um
das einmal deutsch sagen um
freiheitsberaubung versuchte schwere
räuberische erpressung nötigung
gefährliche körperverletzung und
beleidigung all das ist angeklagt und
ich fand sehr spannend dass du ein
interview geführt hast mit dem
strafrechtsprofessor martin jäger und
der hat sehr klar gesagt also der der
tatvorwurf ist eigentlich ziemlich
übersichtlich ja sowas verhandelt man
eigentlich ja in bra fahndungs tagen das
ist schnell durch aber hier geht es
schon wirklich sehr sehr lange warum ist
das so ja das ist eine gute frage und
das bin ich denke mal das hängt damit
zusammen dass man eben diese prominenten
figuren hat das und und dass man da eine
chance drin sieht mal so dieses ganze
milieu auszuleuchten aber man sieht ja
schon daran also dass bushido hat 25
tage da raus gesagt und da ging es ja
nur also das hat ewigkeiten gedauert bis
es dann endlich zu diesem tag kam wurde
diese dieser zentrale vorwurf
stattgefunden haben soll sondern der
richter hat sich dann wirklich am anfang
hingesetzt und gesagt so also ich habe
keine ahnung von dieser rap-szene nur
ich habe nach dem motto ich weiß nicht
wen sehen wir fangen jetzt mal ganz von
vorne an und dann fangen machen wir
wirklich punkt für punkt gehen wir so
ihr leben durch und diese einzelnen
stationen wie haben sie sich
kennengelernt was dann passiert wer kann
da dazu also in einer unglaublichen
ausführlichkeit wird es alles
abgehandelt und
also da habe ich mich schon die ganze
zeit oder irgendwann gefragt wie
verhältnismäßig das eigentlich auch noch
ist weil es einfach so aus und ist bei
diesen dann doch eben am ende jetzt
keine vorwürfe die irgendwie der
schwerkriminalität zum zweiten sind
genau deswegen habe ich das eben auch
diesen staaten strafrechtsprofessor
gefragt und der war eben da auch
skeptischen hat gemeint eigentlich
schritt so was bei solchen vorwürfen in
der einstelligen zahl von
verhandlungstagen abgehandelt also das
ist etwas was in der tat den angeklagten
nicht gefallen kann hast du denn den
eindruck gehabt dass bushido das
gefallen hat den er redet ja sehr gerne
über sein leben es gibt auch einen film
auf amazon über sein leben eine
dokumentation er wurde zwei jahre lang
begleitet und es wird sehr persönliches
beiden also er und seine frau packen
fiel sehr persönliches auch aus auch
über die
dynamik in der beziehung und aber auch
die dynamik zu diesem manager zu abou
chaker wie würdest du sagen hat bushido
diese aussage marathon verkraftet oder
sogar genossen also ich glaube nicht ich
glaube dass das auch nicht in seinem
sinne ist unbedingt dass ich das so
ewigkeiten hinzieht das hat auch der der
anwalt von ihm letztes mal durchblicken
lassen weil er ist jetzt ja auch wir
gekommen war das jetzt hier wieder diese
diese aufregung und so eine kleine neue
wendung gab er ist ja jetzt er
neuerdings auch wieder erschienen das
musste ja dann zwischenzeitlich gar
nicht mehr wenn er nicht ausgesagt hatte
und hat der anwalt auch gesagt dass der
maschine ziehen gesagt hätte wie so wie
kann das denn sein dass das immer immer
weitergeht und mich endlich aufhört die
wiese er scheint da jetzt also selbst
sei dann im zuschauerraum oder wie muss
man sich
einen festen platz aber der wald oft mit
stars und dann bald sein anwalt nur da
zuletzt und jetzt aber wieder gekommen
ja das war dann auch um diese dieses
thema wird es wahrscheinlich noch
sprechen um das zeichen zu setzen dass
dann nicht total von verunsichern lässt
glaube ich ja aber also ich denke der
prozess an sich ist für bushido schon
wichtig auch einfach weil er halt seine
seine erzählung da irgendwie versucht zu
platzieren dass er das opfer war in
dieser ganzen sache und dass sie auch
auf vielen anderen eben dann ihm helfen
kann wenn es dann um zivilrechtliche
streitigkeiten zwischen den leim geht
aber ich glaube nicht dass er es genießt
dass dieser prozess jetzt irgendwie weil
das ich nicht zwei jahre am ende geht
die jetzt hast du schon
es gab eine bemerkenswerte wende in dem
prozess was worum geht's was ist da
aufgetaucht wir hatten ja schon
gesprochen eben von diesem 18 januar
2018 dass der so zentral ist und es gibt
jetzt wohl eine audiodatei die an diesem
tag heimlich erstellt worden sein soll
man muss dazu wissen dass
auf einem handy von arafat abou chaker
mal bei einer durchsuchung da wurde das
handy beschlagnahmt wurden sehr viele
audio dateien gefunden
weil er bei ganz vielen treffen offenbar
sein handy einfach mitlaufen lassen und
dass die anderen das wussten was an sich
schon gestraft hat ist genau das ist in
diesem milieu durchaus üblich ja wo muss
schauen ob beweismittel
zu sammeln aber wahrscheinlich nicht so
sehr um die dann der polizei zu
übergeben sondern einseitig sich dann
auf die fresse hauen zu können
wahrscheinlich nicht im zweifel so genau
dass bei irgendwelchen diskussionen oder
was auch immer dann dann gegen den
anderen verwenden zu können genau auf
diesem handy war aber nicht diese
aufnahme von der von der jetzt in die
rede ist vom 18 januar die bis jetzt auf
einmal
aufgetaucht und da soll es sich eben um
einen zwei stunden lang mitschnitt
handeln würde ihn der stern berichtet
hat und der stern hatte berichtet dass
das quasi die
die vorwürfe komplett entkräften würde
weil eben innerhalb von diesen zwei
stunden also es hat nur zwei stunden
gedauert beispiel hat gesagt hätte
viereinhalb stunden gedauert und dabei
vor allem sind halt nicht diese diese
vorwürfe die erholung basiert also er
sei nicht geschlagen worden mit der
flasche und wo wir auf einem stuhl und
der sei nicht eingeschlossen worden und
ist als friedliches treffen gewesen also
hört sich das schon richtig darstellen
also hört sich diesen stern an aber der
anwalt von bushido hat da sehr
entschieden darauf reagiert und und
wirft ihm
ja auch dem stern vor dass dazu voreilig
über eine seiner meinung nach unter
verschiedenes meinung nach manipulierte
datei berichtet wurde und will jetzt auf
verschiedenen wegen eben nachweisen dass
das zumindest nicht vollständig war
genau das gericht ist aber auch diesen
stern -bericht auch sehr schnell
angesprungen hat wollte vom stern auch
die die aufnahme erst haben hat sie dann
aber schon vorher vor den sternen ob
liefern konnte von den von dem anwalt
von arafat aber stärker bekommen und
will jetzt eben selbst überprüfen was
was an dieser ganzen aufnahme dran sind
ob die jetzt wirklich den den prozess
ins wanken bringt oder ob er doch teile
fehlen uns jetzt nicht so ein
entscheidendes beweisen ist am ende
genau das ist jetzt eine situation die
ganz interessant ist weil einerseits ist
das natürlich illegal
gemacht waren die aufnahme das heißt
eigentlich eine straftat und dann wird
immer diskutiert kann man dann dieses
beweismittel benutzen hier in
deutschland anders als in den
vereinigten staaten das ist eben so dass
sowas dann durchaus obwohl man weiß dass
es eben illegal beschafft wurde und
illegal hergestellt wurde dass das
trotzdem benutzt werden kann in so einem
strafverfahren und das bedeutet aber
nicht dass man jetzt einfach nur sich
das anhört und guckt was da drauf war
sondern das wird sehr umfassend
forensisch untersucht ob da irgendwelche
dinge raus geschnitten wurden ab jg
hinzugefügt wurden und so weiter
und zusätzlich hat also abgesehen davon
dass diese datei wird
will der anwalt von bushido auch noch
andere beweise einbringen zum beispiel
versucht er die daten zu bekommen aus
dem auto mit dem schädel damals gefahren
ist und die sollen beweisen dass er eben
doch vier stunden da vor ort war nicht
nur zwei stunden aber ob das wirklich so
ist das alles noch offen erwartet dass
es dann doch noch ein nebenschauplatz
sozusagen also wo einfach versucht wird
nachzuweisen dass das nicht authentisch
sei
so was ist denn jetzt deine prognose das
ganze wird noch ein weilchen laufen
wahrscheinlich und am ende könnte aber
tatsächlich einen freispruch stehen
wieder einmal ein freispruch stehen oder
wie
ja ich glaube es hängt jetzt also
tatsächlich das gerade mal wieder ein
spannender punkt und das hängt jetzt
glaube ich schon so ein bisschen davon
ab was jetzt bei dieser audiodatei
herauskommt also ob das wirklich jetzt
diesen diesen einen tag da abbildet dann
könnte das natürlich schon wirklich eine
wendung seien in dem prozess aber der
richter weg ist nicht so dass er jetzt
irgendwie ganz schnell dass das
abhandeln und ich denke mal das wird als
ein beweisstück unter vielen einfließen
damit es weitergehen bushido soll jetzt
sogar noch mal kommen und als zeuge
aussagen obwohl seine aussagen schon
abgeschlossen war also wahrscheinlich
nochmal nachfragen
was er jetzt diese aufnahme zu sagen hat
und
ja dann wird sich das weiter hinziehen
und am ende
ich würde sagen das ist immer noch
vollkommen offen was da was da für eine
straffe ob da eine strafe bei rauskommen
wird
aber das ist jetzt irgendwie eine riesen
strafe ist das kann man glauben es
schon echt irre was da passiert gerade
so zwar wirklich
größen prominente menschen die dann
ihren streit offen austragen und sich
auch also
und auch durchaus sehr immer jahre lang
in einem doch der zwielichtigen milieu
wohl gefühlt und auch agiert haben und
jetzt quasi die ressourcen der
justizbehinderung ihre streitigkeiten zu
erregen und nicht
haben sagte shih du ja auch sehr lange
davon profitiert und sich zumindest nach
außen hin auch in dieser verbindung
irgendwie sehr wohl gefühlt heute sagt
er halt das wäre alles nur fassade
gewesen
und runter gründeten aber ja ist schon
ist schon interessant und gleichzeitig
wird er auch also es ist ja auch diese
dieser polizeischutz den er genießt er
ist ja auch mal vor vor das heißt
genießt wird das ist wahrscheinlich
jetzt auch nicht schön ist aber er steht
unter polizeischutz eine ganze familie
das sieht man auch bevor ich damit davon
maskierten polizisten
[Musik]
reingebracht also es ist schon insgesamt
eine sehr sehr angespannte lage und
letztendlich ist es so dass es das aber
auch noch nicht das ende vom lied ist es
wenn es da jetzt ein urteil gibt es
werden noch oder es sind noch
zivilrechtliche streitigkeiten anhängig
zwischen den beinen na ja genau da geht
es ja noch um sehr viel geld die haben
ja einen allein schon ein riesiges
grundstück sich zusammen gekauft wo sie
mehr drauf stehen dann muss ich nicht
zusammen wohnen wollen das soll jetzt
irgendwie zwangsversteigert werden dann
geht es darum wer bekommt wie viel geld
sie haben noch ein anderes riesiges
immobilienprojekt
und dann geht es eben auch noch um die
ganze musik geschäfte also das ist der
eigentlich wahrscheinlich entscheidende
schauplatz und ja das ist natürlich wenn
jetzt in dem strafprozess
der vor dem schalker verurteilt werden
sollte dann wäre das wahrscheinlich ein
gutes argument auch in diesen
zivilprozessen
ja in der tat also das bewirke justiz in
berlin noch lange lange beschäftigen
herzlichen dank sebastian dass er uns da
mal ein blick in diesen doch sehr
anderen frei gegeben hast ich sehr gerne
dann wird wir jetzt bei der hörer post
die letzte woche wieder mannigfaltig
eintrudelte herzlichen dank dafür da
sind wir immer sehr dankbar wenn von
unseren der kundigen hörerinnen und
hörer da im pott kommt und ich wollte
mal aufgreifen das gerechte urteil von
vergangener woche wo es darum ging das
alles
pärchen ein kind bekommen hat und dann
eine frau sich zum mann hat umwandeln
das und die frage war kann diese frau
oder die personen die früher als
biologisch als frau gegolten hat nun der
vater des kindes werden und da hatte ja
das zuständige amtsgericht eine sehr
pragmatische lösung gefunden hat gesagt
ja das muss gehen das haben wir auch
sehr gerecht als sehr gerecht empfunden
unsere standesbeamten denn jeder sagt
aber dass deutsche abstimmungsrechte ist
größtenteils weiterhin auf die
biologischen abstammung ausgerichtet die
vermutung dass der ehemann der mutter
der vater eines kindes ist dürfte auch
heute noch fast immer richtig sein für
den fall dass dies ausnahmsweise nicht
zutrifft kann die vaterschaft
angefochten werden das war zudem unserem
argumente dass es in heterosexuellen
konstellation ja auch so ist dass die
ehe automatisch bedeutet dass der mann
eben der vater setzte und offenkundig
ist das ist nicht so es aber sie sagt
eben die vermutung ist auch in weiten
teilen richtig während umgekehrt die
ehefrau der mutter ist dagegen nie vater
oder mutter ja also auch hier ist dann
ihm klar dass die zweite person das
zweite elternteil
eben nicht der vater sein kann
biologisch und daher sollte auch keine
gesetzliche abstimmungs vermutung
konstruiert werden auch ein mann der als
frau geboren wurde kann nicht biologisch
vater eines kindes sein so und dann
stellt sie eben klar dass die
entsprechende norm der von § 11 ist die
rede transsexuellengesetz soll wieder
ein elternteil chef schaffen noch
ausschließen sondern er regelt lediglich
dass die bezeichnung vater oder mutter
zu dem kind bestehen
bleibt so und sie sagt ganz klar auch
ich bin der meinung dass es
gleichgeschlechtlichen paaren möglich
sein sollte durch erklärung co vater
oder mutter zu werden ohne dass ein
aufwendiges adoptionsverfahren
durchlaufen werden muss das könnte mit
einer erklärung ähnlich einer
vaterschaft erkennung auch ermöglicht
werden das müsse aber durch ein gesetz
ermöglicht werden und es kann nicht
aufgabe der gerichte sein der regelung
zu schaffen ich glaube da hat unsere
hörerinnen auch sehr recht wir hatten
das ja auch in der letzten woche
durchaus gesagt dass wir dieses urteil
sehr gerecht fanden im ergebnis aber es
war in der begründung schon so dass es
eigentlich fast dass das ich glaube es
war das amtsgericht regensburg
tatsächlich fast schon gegen das gesetz
argumentieren musste um zu diesem
ergebnis zu kommen also ich glaube dass
daniela da er in der rein juristischen
auffassung total richtig liegt und
wahrscheinlich auch im pragmatischen
weil sieben also wir das ja durchaus
auch als sinnvoll sehen und das war ja
sozusagen der vorteil des ganzen ist
dieses kind dann in zwei elternteile hat
aber sie waren ein dadurch würde
verhindert werden dass der biologische
vater des kindes eingetragen werden kann
da und das wie gesagt ist ja eine sehr
schwierige konstellation die immer
wieder eine rolle spielt auch vor den
gerichten ja und da und das ist aber
auch ein durchaus verfassungsrechtlich
abgesicherte anspruch ja insbesondere
auch des kindes also der
verfassungsrechtlichen anspruch auf
kenntnis der abstammung würde dadurch
verhindert werden oder zumindest
erschwert werden warnte sie ein das
wollten wir hier mal als gegenmeinung
vortragen kann sich jeder auch eine
andere meinung bin oder dem auch
zustimmen wir wollten das so zu sagen
hier meine vorstellig kite weil wir es
auch in sehr gelungenen und der kundigen
beitrag von hier mal zum besten geben
und wir entschuldigen uns gleichzeitig
dass wir auch tatsächlich in diesen
ganzen in der ganzen terminologie nicht
immer ganz sattelfest sind aber wir
lernen gerne dazu bekommen hin und
wieder auch mal
zuschriften wo wir sehr freundlich
darauf hingewiesen werden
wie man das besser und richtiger und
richtig vor allen dingen ja diskutiert
wir bemühen uns dass immer auch dann in
der nächsten folge besser zu machen
ich hoffe es ist uns gelungen sonst
bitte schreiben sie uns schreibt uns da
freuen wir uns darüber
außerdem haben wir hier noch eine sehr
freudige nachricht bekommen von unserem
hörer marx der auch jetzt soll ich das
zweite staatsexamen gekommen ist mit
einem prädikat und sich hervorragend
vorbereitet führte durch diesen podcast
herzlichen dank oder herzlichen
glückwunsch wünschen wir und auch
herzlichen dank für diese netten worte
ja genau und er hat auch versprochen
dass sobald der erste job winkt dann
auch ein abo abgeschlossen wird und da
wollten wir an dieser stelle auch noch
mal erinnern wer vor durch uns
profitiert und wir hoffen wir dass das
alle hören und hörer tun und uns
unterstützen möchte kann dies gerne tun
durch einen faz einspruch abo das kann
man mal kostenlos testen und dann ist es
auch wirklich nicht besonders hohen
preisen
käuflich zu erwerben und dann würden wir
uns sehr freuen weil uns das natürlich
hier weiterbringt so also dass meine
kleinen werbeblock und jetzt kommen wir
zum richten urteil
das überhaupt nicht gerecht diese woche
es geht um ein ungerechtes urteil aus
dem sauerland über das ich ehrlich
gesagt erst mal gelacht habe als ich das
gelesen habe ich glaube es war bei den
kollegen vom spiegel dass ich das
gelesen habe und zwar hat das
landgericht arnsberg eine 79-jährige
frau vom vorwurf sie stalker den
örtlichen pfarrer freigesprochen weil
sie schuldunfähig sei wegen liebeswahn
kann man erst mal ein bisschen drüber
lachen zum einen natürlich liebes waren
erstmal ein sehr hübsches wort ist es
irgendwie immer so ein bisschen nach
asterix und obelix klingt ist aber
überhaupt nicht lustig muss man sagen
also diese ganze geschichte ist völlig
irre 20 jahre alt diese frau und dieser
fahrer kennen sich seit dem jahr 2001
damals hat er sie seelsorgerisch betreut
das ist wohl erst ihre mutter und dann
ihr vater gestorben und offensichtlich
seit diesem zeitpunkt ist diese frau ist
wird man kann sich anders sagen von dem
mann besessen im sauerland also seit 20
jahren meldet sie sich mindestens
wöchentlich in aller regel aber täglich
und zwar mit melden meine ich sie ruft
ihn an sie schickt ihm sms geschickt die
mails sie schickt ihn liebesbriefe sie
ruft ihm wenn er auf seinem grundstück
herum läuft obszöne worte zu sie tanzt
aber auch ab und zu mal im garten des
pfarrhauses in freien all das ist ein
ortsteil von national man muss dazu
sagen meine eltern stammen aus dem
sauerland das heißt ich weiß wovon ich
rede die tanz dabei dem nackt im garten
herum dank dem garten herum ja es ist
dass die hängt luftballons in seinem
garten auf auf denen steht ich liebe
dich und sie hat mein persönlicher
favorit seinen garten mit phallus
symbole dekoriert also mit möhren und
bananen das ganze ist jetzt halt
wirklich man lacht drüber wenn man
einmal liest wenn man sich mal zehn
sekunden vorstellen wie sich das
anfühlen muss über 20 jahre lang so
terrorisiert zu werden ist das halt
überhaupt nicht mehr witzig in der
fahrer der davon betroffenen es leidet
mittlerweile dann auch an starkem
bluthochdruck unter schlafstörungen und
ist nach eigenen angeben angaben also
erheblich gesundheitlich beeinträchtigt
und zwar auch psychisch der ist also
nach eigenen angaben selbst in
psychotherapeutischer behandlung seit
jahren sind wie gesagt 20 jahre da kommt
eine menge zusammen es gab 80 verfahren
bei der staatsanwaltschaft ich habe
gestern mit den sehr netten
pressesprecher des landgerichts arnsberg
noch telefoniert der hat mir noch so ein
bisschen hintergrund infos zu dem
verfahren gegeben diese verfahren waren
natürlich alle gleich gelagert es ging
immer um stalking aber alle anderen
wurden eingestellt nur zwei mal hat die
staatsanwaltschaft angeklagt und beim
ersten mal ist das schon genau so
gelaufen wie jetzt auch nämlich das
amtsgericht hat gesagt ja tatbestand des
dopings ist erfüllt um diese frau ist
auch schuldfähig und hat damals 14
monate haft verhängt und dann kam das
landgericht in arnsberg und hat gesagt
nein tatbestand ist zweifelt aber die
frau schuldunfähig und jetzt ist genau
dasselbe nochmal passiert und deswegen
wollten wir uns dass so ein bisschen für
euch anschauen ich habe erst mal gefragt
warum denn einig die staatsanwaltschaft
jetzt überhaupt noch mal angeklagt hat
weil ich meinen 80 anzeigen und
irgendwann sagte ich wahrscheinlich die
zuständige behörde bei der polizei bei
der staatsanwaltschaft auch so auch gott
schon wieder dieser fahrer was sollen
wir denn machen sozusagen aber es ist
wohl so dass der sich das überhaupt
nicht gefallen lassen will sondern er
versucht sich vehement gehör zu
verschaffen und das hin bis zum landtag
in düsseldorf und das hat dann wohl
immerhin dazu geführt dass jetzt die
staatsanwaltschaft noch mal angeklagt
hat noch mal wegen 238 strafgesetzbuch
also der tatbestand des nachstellens das
kann einiges talking heißen im deutschen
strafgesetzbuch
das amtsgericht hat die frau auch
verurteilt dieses mal zu neun monaten
haft auf bewährung das ging also davon
aus die den tatbestand des stalkings
rechtswidrig und schuldhaft verwirklicht
hat vielleicht mal ganz kurz für die
nicht juristinnen und juristen unter uns
verurteilt werden kann man nur wenn man
einen straftatbestand nicht nur erfüllt
sondern auch noch rechtswidrig und
schuldhaft erfüllt
das amtsgericht hat hier übrigens
genauso wie das landgericht relativ
unproblematisch gesagt dass der
tatbestand des nachstellens wohl
ziemlich easy going erfüllt ist also
nachstellen ist sozusagen sich bei
jemanden ständig melden seine räumliche
nähe suchen über telekommunikations
medienkontakt zudem aufnehmen in einer
weise die geeignet ist die
lebensgestaltung nicht unerheblich zu
beeinflussen
das war noch der alte straftatbestand
der wurde ende 20 21 geändert früher
brauchte man eine schwerwiegende
beeinträchtigung der lebensgestaltung
ich glaube auch die wäre bei täglichen
ja stalking versuchen wie von dieser
frau unproblematische erfüllt gewesen
nach aktuellem recht würde mit
sicherheit sogar ein besonders schwerer
fall vorliegen weil eben das opfer in
seiner gesundheit geschädigt ist und
weil man auch davon ausgeht dass ein
besonders schwerer stalking fall schon
bei mehr als sechs monaten belästigung
stattfindet und ich meine wir sprechen
hier von 20 jahren also kein problem
tatbestand verwirklicht und das
amtsgericht ist halt auch davon
ausgegangen dass die frau schuldfähig
war das hat in über diese frau schon
mehrere gutachten gegeben eben auch in
mehreren verfahren
auch vor dem landgericht arnsberg wo
dann jetzt die berufung auch wieder
gelandet ist wurde wieder ein gutachten
eingeholt die meisten der gutachter laut
dem pressesprecher mit dem ich gestern
gesprochen habe waren der auffassung
dass diese frau
nicht schuldfähig ist so auch der jetzt
eingeschaltete gutachter professor
norbert leygraf von der uni münster
seine diagnose lautet nämlich
tatsächlich und das heißt wirklich so
wahnhafte störung in der form eines
liebeswahn also die kann es gar nicht
mehr steuern und was verbirgt sich genau
das ist wirklich eine psychische
krankheit die es die schuld
ausschließend wirken kann weil die
nämlich davon ausgeht also die es sich
wirklich sicher dass der fahrer ihre
liebe erwidert das aber als katholischer
pfarrer nicht zu geben und nicht zeigen
kann weil er das ja nicht darf deine es
ja katholischer pfarrer und dieser
gutachter hat sich wohl hat mir der
gerichtssprecher eben auch erzählt schon
zeit seines lebens mit dieser
problematik des liebespaares beschäftigt
und hat dazu geforscht um tatsächlich
sinn davon wohl deutlich
überproportional katholische priester
betroffen weil die natürlich geeignete
objekte führung liebeswahn sind denn da
kann man sich natürlich super als
verliebter mensch sagen der liebt mich
eigentlich der darf noch nicht zeigen
denn der historische fahrer also das ist
schon wirklich sehr smokie und bei
dieser frau kommt spezifisch wohl noch
hinzu dass sie unter hirnorganischen
veränderungen leidet also sie hatten
abbauprozess im hirn kern das heißt
bestimmte dinge funktionieren total
super also gedächtnis orientierung
merkfähigkeit aber die urteilsfähigkeit
und die möglichkeit ihr eigenes
verhalten zu steuern sind eingeschränkt
und das kann man wohl sogar auch im mrt
sehen diesen sichtbaren abbauprozess im
hirn kern und diese kombination führt
laut dem gutachter eben dazu dass sie
ihr verhalten weder richtig einschätzen
noch ist entsprechend steuern könnte und
das irre an diese geschichte ist ja ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob ihre das richtige
wort ist aber deswegen fallen wie es
ungerecht und deswegen fand ich es
ungerecht ist dass man eine sagt okay
sie schuldunfähig
deswegen kann sie nicht auf bewährung
verurteilt werden aber auf der anderen
seite kann man auch sagen aber das sagen
die auch da können wir auch nichts
machen ja also es ist jetzt umgekehrt
auch nicht so schlimm dass wir sie
einweisen müssen dass wir sie in eine
behandlung geben müssen das wie ihr
auflegen können dass tatsächlich mal
anzugehen und das finde ich ehrlich
gesagt wirklich ziemlich
dass das lässt einen sprachlos zurück
also da habe ich natürlich auch mit dem
pressesprecher darüber gesprochen haben
noch mal nachgefragt und das ist halo
johanna schaut euch an echt spannend der
63 strafgesetzbuch also da geht es eben
darum was können gerichte denn
eigentlich tun wenn man sagt man hat so
eine rechtswidrige tat begangen aber
eben schuldunfähig normalerweise oder
das heißt normalerweise in vielen fällen
ordnen gerichtet dann eben genau diese
unterbringung in einem psychiatrischen
krankenhaus an die du angesprochen hast
corinna aber dafür gibt es natürlich
hohe hürden was ihren ersten mal auch
nichts schlechtes ist weil man möchte ja
auch nicht weil man irgendwie vielleicht
sich mal nicht besonders gut benommen
hat plötzlich eingewiesen werden in
psychiatrische krankenhäuser von
gerichten man bräuchte dafür erhebliche
rechtswidrige taten zu erwarten sind und
man muss davon ausgehen dass der täter
für die allgemeinheit gefährlich ist und
da hat das dann kriegt arnsberg gesagt
bei aller liebe da kommen wir nicht
drüber denn es ist weder diese stalking
ist wieder eine in diesem sinne
erhebliche rechtswidrige taten
noch wird die allgemeinheit dadurch
gefährdet denn ihr liebeswahn richtet
sich ja nur auf eine person nämlich auf
diesen einfacher und nach herrschender
meinung reicht eine person eben nicht
aus um so eine gefährdung der
allgemeinheit zu überwinden die man halt
bräuchte um jemanden einzuweisen ich hab
das krankenhaus aber es klingt natürlich
in den ohren des fahrers wahrscheinlich
wie hohen ich finde auch dass sich das
wirklich schon fast schon höhnisch oder
oder zynisch anhört und man hätte sich
durchaus überlegen können finde ich
persönlich bei dieser intensität aber
vor allem auch bei dieser dauer dieses
talking durchaus als erhebliche straftat
einzustufen und vielleicht auch ihm mit
blick auf die intensität und die dauer
zu sagen na ja das könnte jetzt schon
irgendwie gefährlich für die
allgemeinheit in form einer person sein
denn diese person hat halt überhaupt
kein normales leben mehr
diese sagt man nicht da dass es wirklich
ein erheblicher rechtswidriger eingriff
ist also diese wertung habe mich auch
nie überzeugt dass du mein das nennt das
wurde ja auch auf offensichtlich ab
gewinner also keiner keine hinreichend
erhebliche straftat so genau also das
ist so ein bisschen na ja das ist schon
so etwas definiert durch welche die
opfer seelisch oder körperlich erheblich
geschädigt oder erheblich gefährdet
werden oder schwerer wirtschaftlicher
schaden angerichtet wird steht im gesetz
und er deshalb für die allgemeinheit
gefährlich ist das heißt man braucht
diese voraussetzungen hat kumulativ und
das lange tanz beim clean gesagt wir
sehen keine von beiden also ich finde
man kann das jetzt sozusagen formal
juristisch gesehen schon nachvollziehen
und das tat dem landgericht az natürlich
auch sehr leid also die kamera hat das
auch sehr bedauert aber sie sieht ihre
hände gebunden sagen so was wie mit den
mitteln des strafrechts ist es ist
einfach dem problem nicht beizukommen
das bringt allerdings den betroffenen
fahrer muss man einfach ehrlich mal
sagen überhaupt nichts rechtskräftig ist
die geschichte noch nicht man könnte
noch das exakt heute revision einlegen
nur wer sollte das tun der fahrer ist ja
nicht beteiligt auch nicht als
nebenkläger und selbst die
staatsanwaltschaft hatte freispruch
beantragt weil alle davon ausgehen dass
die frau nicht schuldfähig sind ist also
muss man am ende einfach traurig hier
rausgehen und sagen in dieser woche ein
äußerst ungerechtes urteil zumindest mit
einem sehr unbefriedigenden ergebnis
wenn man doch keiner weise man von
darüber nachdenkt ja ja ja
also so ist es dann mal auch dass mit
diesen konstellationen muss das recht
kämpfen und scheitert eben auch manchmal
so ist das im leben aber dann hoffen wir
auf einem größeren käufer
auf gerechte urteil nächste woche da es
ihnen borowski wieder am start mit dir
zusammen und wir hoffen natürlich auf
ein weiterhin friedlichen verlauf das in
der ukraine
und auch sonst auf der welt wir wünschen
einen schönen rest woche sowieso wir
wünschen allen weltfrieden bleibt uns
gewogen da draußen habt eine gute woche
lotto
tschüss